braves gnats first of three we're going
to be underway
more than three hours late should be the
latest start at nationals park since
saturday august 12th of 17. and just
moments ago the nationals presented ryan
zimmerman with a game worn jersey and
the lineup card from yesterday's
historic appearance in new york when
ryan played in his 1760
ballgame here's his arsenal in case
you're wondering opponents hitting 222
against the fastball
222 against the slider curveball change
to complement it
looked like a swing
alfonso marquez the crew chief down at
third concurs and the long-awaited first
out of the night pick it up right where
he left off last start against the
braves we just told you about the 10
strikeouts and that's how
this one begins with a strikeout of ozzy
albee's
pretty well executed
97
miles per hour
now that's moving around on a friday
night and a very impressive one two
three
charlie morton and that ball is ripped
that ball is fair
and victor robles cruising into second
on the first pitch he sees tonight
he's now seven for his last 20.
maybe the latest there goes the no
hitter but there goes the no hitter a
lead off double
for victor robles
cruising in the second
pulls it breaks his bat that's gonna
drop onto the grass victor robles was
ready to go home and bob henley said
stop big fella
first and third nobody out and how about
escobar way behind in the count getting
a knock and soto coming up so bad guy's
a hero good stop by bob henley at third
he stops someone bob
look he's got a stop sign
it's a good thing he did
juan's been all over the bases lately
with hits and walks
soda center field that ball's on the
ground
skipping deep into the gap row plays
home escobar to third soto delivers rbi
number
62
and the nets are on top
line moving
here in the bottom of the first the two
strike approach by juan soto a laser to
right center chuck peterson does a nice
job of cutting this ball off but an easy
first to third for ocd's escobar
same beds
and bell hits it well the other way
escobar back to tag he takes off throw
home by duvall cut off two nothing
nationals
four good at bats to start the late
night
boston riley's still a pup he just
turned 24 early april
and josiah showing him the repertoire
here
some heat upstairs
some breaking stuff in the dirt and he
has fanned three of the four hitters
in six in the third innings against the
atlanta braves josiah gray has struck
out 13 of them
and six and a third
good way to start your career and then
he freezes duval how about this
six up six down
two strikeouts in each inning so far and
a two run lead with which to work
two from charlie the ball is punched to
the left side to his left answer swansea
picks 360 spin and a bullet oh to
freddie freeman to retire asides escobar
that's a beautiful play by dansby
swanson out at short and a 1-2-3 inning
and now the young left-hander garcia
gets a chance to add on
and it's smacked into left field that's
down for a hit here comes the runner
around third bell is chugging the throw
to the plate is on the money and bell
never got to the dish
another great throw from duvall erases
josh bell
charlie morton gives up the hit but
atlanta erases bell it's still
two-nothing this is empty travis darno
the atlanta catcher
and this one is hammered toward left
field that ball is gone
travis darneau has hit a homer and the
braves are right back in the game
he's had both atlanta hits
and that's got to be a very satisfying
trip around the bases
his first homer back off the injured
list
anger here's you know he but you see he
got him out front but good hitters like
travis he was able to stay back enough
and the only thing
you knew what this was going to be if it
was
high enough to get out and he was able
to just sneak in the flower bed
top of the order ozzy albies
not this time unloads deep to right
field did he get enough at the wall he
did he ties it up
he wasn't getting to two strikes this at
bat jeff
and the home run ball bites gray young
braves fan has a souvenir and a smile
and we're tied at two
third game in a row for ozzy with the
home run ozzie took the approach if i'm
gonna see you ball up
he got the curve ball up in the zone
and tied this ball game on austin
riley's over two with a strikeout
tonight
2-2
fastball rifled center field deep braves
have the lead well all night austin
riley chip has not been able to catch up
to that fastball
right here he gets one down in the zone
and gets a huge home run to give the
braves a lead
in his last 21 games
driven to right center that's beautiful
so gray as good as he is
has served up three more homers tonight
107 off the bat
tying run
is pereira he's at third base
oh two
hard hit ball and tans be scouted on a
dive
boy oh boy the nationals hit a whole lot
of rockets in the seventh but the braves
in the right place at the right time to
preserve a 3-2 lead
winsby swanson a infield hit last time
up
swing and a high fly ball toward left
center field dansby swanson with the
fourth solo homer for the braves tonight
well he missed the 3-1 and machado came
and he knew it looking to put his head
down right when he hit it see the out
[Applause]
that ball's launched look at it chip
it's over the red seats and into the
tables
jabal's two strikes
here it is
swaying and a miss escobar chased ball
three and the braves come back from a
two-nothing deficit with four solo home
runs to get the road trip off to a great
start atlanta is back in first place a
4-2 thriller in washington tonight